all right right now it is 6.05 on a
friday and a taste of new orleans is
rolling into downtown las vegas for
mardi gras
or fat tuesday we're talking cajun food
king cake a lot of beads john yeah with
hector apparently it's all those three
things
vegas test kitchen in downtown las vegas
over at ferguson's is whipping up some
traditional dishes for us
for you as well they're hosting a
limited dining event this weekend hector
mejia is there live this morning
to explain how those celebrations will
be this year hector you're already in a
very festive mood
yeah you know i only got three beats not
all of them there are stacks of beads
out there for you guys but
this is the area they've decorated this
alleyway is the focal point here so
the whole idea is without the massive
crowds or the wild
parties we can wild out over food
socially distanced of course out there
in the distance we have
backstage dancers from maybe lady gaga
or share productions just kidding
no they're not but we are actually
having a wonderful time
here and joining us live we have justin
hall with main street provisions we've
actually profiled main street provisions
when they opened in december
you're here to talk to us about the
delicious dishes for the entire weekend
good morning
good morning to you yeah it's
super exciting time julie menina down at
the vegas test kitchen
they have a lot of different food events
going on all weekend
all the way to fat tuesday on well on
tuesday the 16th
which is where i come in um we have
some really cool people doing food for
uh for all day i'll be
gumbo right yep uh i'll be doing uh
oyster stuffed coil gumbo
they've got tickets on secretburger.com
120
for two people they get food they get
cocktails
uh provided by lisa breyer our cocktail
maiden over at mainstream provisions
also
justin you know looking at this a lot of
preparation went into this
the mardi gras crew working for i don't
know how
long days weeks and now here we are
yeah it's uh i mean to see them
transform the alleyways down here uh
near the ferguson is like pretty
incredible you can see like everything
they've done
the colors the lights chairs it's going
to be a totally special weekend for
people to get out
uh your best part of mardi gras the
beads
uh best part for me is actually just
being behind the gumbo pot
i really love just serving people up and
this is another great chance to kind of
you know see people in these times and
get to serve them
every chef has a secret recipe i'm not
going to ask you for your secret recipe
but what's your secret touch
for the food my secret touch usually is
the fact that i'm always by a fire
you know i think if i didn't smell like
smoke half the time
my family would think it's kind of weird
so
all right thank you very much so we'll
be talking a lot more about the food
about the dancing
everything the king cake everything that
has to do with mardi gras
a few minutes from now but for now
reporting live hector mejia
eight nice now back to you guys i love
the music
yeah hector you have three beads on
because you've thrown the rest
somewhere i did and
you know it hit some people but
thankfully they're okay
you know what that's one way to wake up
and get beats through your face all
right
hector thank you so much